hi in this video I'm going to talk about
affinity chromatography affinity
chromatography is a good method for
protein purification so affinity
purification are utilizes our affinity
tag it could be a histidine affinity tab
or it could be a GST affinity tag so
let's see why do we need actually
affinity chromatography say for instance
we want to work with a particular
protein of our interest so our
particular protein of interest is say
protein a so now we have a gene
corresponding to this protein a which
will encode for protein a now what we
would do we would actually put this gene
inside these expression vector for
example say it's a bacterial expression
vector so that we can we can ask the
bacteria to express our protein so this
is our gene of interest inside the
material expression vector and now what
we would do we would transform the
bacteria with our expression vector so
now our bacteria is transformed with the
expression vector and the bacteria would
multiply over time producing many many
bacteria here you can see it is
producing many many bacteria and each
time the expression vector would express
inside the bacteria and would produce a
lot of proteins protein of our
interesting obviously so the bacteria
would produce a lot of protein of our
interest
now what we would do we have to actually
purify
our protein so now how we could purify
the protein and in this case affinity
chromatography is the solution because
when we lies the bacteria there are a
lot of proteins the necessary protein
for the bacteria in the pool of proteins
our protein would be lost and we can't
find it that is why we need a affinity
tag a tag that would help us to
recognize that it is our protein so in
this way we can easily purify our
protein from a pool of let's say 100
proteins we can easily purify our own
protein so let's say a bit more about
the cloning procedure so what we will do
during the time of cloning we can we can
use a C terminal C terminal history can
we do we can use a in terminal we can
use an n-terminal his tagged so his tag
is basically a hexa histidine tag so
this his tag is generally comes with the
vector the expression vector it has a
histidine tag here it's denoted in
purple so now we would clone our gene of
interest in one of these vectors maybe a
C terminal tag B to n terminal tag that
doesn't matter so here is the sequence
corresponding to that C terminal tag and
in terminal tag and after cloning these
thing what we would do we would
transform our bacteria with these
expression vectors which contain our
gene of interest now the bacteria would
produce the protein and we have to
purify the protein and we would see how
these whole affinity chromatography
works so here affinity chromatography is
just a column chromatography so it has a
column packed with beads packed with
matrix I would say so this matrix is
called n int a metrics
in inti metrics and in a moment we would
see how this matrix works so the
principle in a nutshell is like we put
our bacterial isit which contain our
protein along with many other proteins
and now what would happen due to our
protein has a Selective tags our protein
would bind to the matrix and the rest of
the protein protein would be washed out
next we would use a particular type of
elution buffer by which we can elute our
protein and thus we would get our
purified protein now let's zoom in to
these are what we say we would say this
is a bead affinity bead actually so in
this affinity bead if we say it's an int
R matrix so this n int matrix looks like
somewhat this it has uh niccola it has a
lot of other organic moieties with it
but what is notable is that we have a
hexa histidine tag in the n-terminal or
the c terminal of our t side protein
so these hexa histidine tag two of the
histidine would actually coordinate
early coordinate with these nickel and
form a coordinate bond
thus it can get attached with the matrix
here you can see the representation it
is getting attached with the metric
matrix so first when we put all the
bacterial I set along with our protein
and all non-essential proteins of the
bacteria so it will come down this path
and only our protein of interest which
have this hexa histidine tag would be
bound in the matrix or other proteins
such as these blue proteins or these
black ones they are washed out when I
when we are using a washing buffer so
this step is wash tip so this is a wash
tip we are using a washing buffer to
wash out all the nonspecific bindings
and on the unnecessary proteins that we
don't need and then when we use a
elution buffer that's the illusion step
solution buffer would elude our protein
of interest
now in a bit details let's see how the
elution buffer actually elude our
protein of interest so as per elution
buffer we would used Amida's own
imidazoles
ring type of structure so histidine also
have an immediate solid ring so when we
put images all in the last step so
imidazole we competitively inhibit the
histidine hex a student tag to get bind
with the matrix in this way the protein
containing hexa hexa detects a histidine
tag which is bound to the matrix would
be released easily and that is how we
would get our protein into the fraction
collector and thus we would get our
protein of interest so this is a very
important method to get a purified
protein so not only we would use
histidine tags there are other tags
available like GST tag GST means
glutathione is transfer is it's an
enzyme which selectively binds to G SH
so our bids would be labeled with GS h
and our protein should have a GST tag
and the binding mechanism is same and
here we always have a illusion step and
definitely we'll have a wash tip and
this is how we can actually purify our
protein by affinity chromatography hope
you enjoyed the video please like and
subscribe thank you